good morning from westminster well the
story today is the prime minister
appearing before the liaison committee
this is the chairpeople of the 32 select
committees all get together and discuss
an issue of national importance and
today they're going to be talking about
the scottish referendum the impact it's
had on you unity within the united
kingdom and what it means for uh
devolution not just to scotland but also
to the rest of the uk
i think the other interesting thing
today is this report about obesity which
finds that we are
it's costing 47 billion pounds a year
that's more than we spend on uh wars and
terrorism if you save that amount of
money you could pay for the police the
judicial system and the prisons combined
and i think
the recommendations that they're coming
up with are pretty stringent including
changing portion sizes
for fast food packaged meals so the
government will be having a look at that
and seeing whether they should take any
of those recommendations on board